big brother all stars season two
is finally happening it's happening it's
happening and you are a part of it is
this surreal
well it's my second all-star so you know
who would have thought
uh so i'm happy and i'm happy to be here
i'll take it i answered the call
so yeah what was your reaction to the
call
um you know i thought they uh i thought
they accidentally butt dialed me
um and and uh so they they confirmed
that that was not the case
that it was intentional so i was still
shocked nonetheless
i mean you've played this game several
times at this point
what is your drive to finally win like
uh you know what i'm always i've got
ambition to
excel and to um you know just do better
than the last time
always in life this is not this is not a
special case so
if anyone that knows me knows that like
i i'm always just trying to outperform
so this is another opportunity where i'm
like you know what i get to do it in
front of
millions of people why not let's do this
i think i read in your bio you are
quote obsessed with being better than
you once were
obsessed yeah so you know i um
i currently uh have you know
an executive position at a biotech
company i have people that report to me
and one of the things that we always try
to push for is something i always expect
from my people
is that i tell them to obsess over the
details
obsessed over being better than you once
were
and so that doesn't matter you know who
else is doing what
um at the end of the day it's how you do
against yourself
so how is your finger preparing
for this season is it ready to hold a
button again
we'll super glue it to anybody uh that
comes my way
i it'll never happen again look it's
less about the button it was more about
the
the willingness to trust somebody that
didn't deserve it so
i think um you know moving forward i'll
have to just you know my calculations
were a little off last time so
uh learn your lesson are you doing some
better math this time around
i am definitely better with math this
time when i'm when i'm trying to
formulate a strategy when when other
people are
you know at play so i really i can't
imagine you you held that button for 14
hours didn't you
yeah that was the longest competition
that's ever gone on at
in big brother history so and i could
have gone even longer i mean we watched
the sun go down
and then come back up and i know people
from production left
to go home and come back and they said
what the heck is going on here
what do you mean you could have gone for
longer how was your finger doing that
do you have the world's strongest finger
what did it look like after that well
you know what um
when i focus on something and
and set my mind to it i can do anything
one thing you'll realize about me that
that's probably
why i succeed is i'm extremely
resilient and when somebody is telling
me no
i come back really hard and i make sure
i win
so that's that's what happened i you
know
i i don't i don't like to be second best
so
was your finger i don't mean to harp on
this but was your finger like
frozen like after you pulled it off
there what was the must
watch it it's been 15 years
so i'll try to recall as best as i can
but i
i i think it was like frozen in
in one place and uh as you can imagine
i i lost all feeling
patient in the finger so at that point i
was thinking
whatever i mean what's another couple
hours like i they might
i can't feel my finger i don't know
what's gonna happen after this
all right well how will you do this time
do you plan to win this thing
oh heck yeah i'm not gonna take all this
time away from work and family
um to come in uh
anything but first place i think i know
i know how to play this game uh i know
what it takes and
i'm i'm i'm gunning for the gold uh
that's somebody who works in a biotech i
mean i don't know exactly what your
field is but
how did you feel about playing in the
middle of a global pandemic
i think it's the perfect time i mean
how well i mean look at you you're
cooped up in your house
um and with nowhere to go so how what
better way to
uh get ready to get cooped up in another
house i'm just going from one house to
another
so you know hey this is this is you know
we've all been stuck at home for three
months and so
now you get to watch some other house
for three months
yeah a little bit of a change of scenery
yeah exactly so i feel like
this cast is either going to be
over the top insane because everybody's
already been so cooped up
or they'll be a little bit more sane
because they've been cooped up so
it's just same old same old listen i
don't i never put the
words sane and big brother in one
sentence
so i think that's probably not the
direction we're going uh
not to mention the pandemic has caused
uh the entire world to lose its damn
mind so
um from my perspective this is gonna
probably be a power keg that we're gonna
watch explode on national television
you know what the people at home thank
you because we need
that powder keg distraction you guys
ordered so here
and i don't know how i got i found
myself in the mix once again this is
probably not the year but you know what
i answered the call and here i am
well if this season is going to explode
who
do you hope to see as part of that
explosion is there anybody who you hope
will be in the cast and anybody who you
might dread
will be on this cast you know um look
there's two
two sides of the coin obviously i want
people i can align with us
that are trustworthy i play a certain
type of game that's principled
and so i need really even keel
uh like-minded individuals so um i need
to create
an alliance and so people who maybe from
my past i don't know
someone like janelle would be awesome
she's definitely an all-star
um and then you know obviously i want to
play against
um incredible folks who know what
they're doing so
i don't want to just race through the
game that's no fun so
the likes of derrick dan obviously
uh these guys played an impeccable game
so
going up against them would be really
really fun
well it's been a minute since you were
on our television screens
um there could be it's been so long
since we had another all-star season
there could be
you know house guests who haven't been
on a long time and then there could be
very new house guests
who do you think will have an advantage
between those two groups
i you know i don't i don't know if old
versus new is really
the dichotomy that's going to give an
advantage over uh
over one over the other um you know i
think
ultimately the personality traits um
is is really what sets people apart uh
to
to get ahead so um look i think there's
advantages
uh obviously youth is good because you
know you're sharp you're fast
and you're strong uh but you know life
experience is also very good
so we'll see how kind of things uh pan
out
uh in the past and on the show people
are very ageist and say
well you know i'm sorry you're gonna
have to go because you're over the age
of 31
and so so you're out um so i don't know
what's gonna happen this season i think
it'll probably skew a little older well
um
we we don't know what kind of
competitions we could get this time
around but
how do you foresee the competitions
potentially being
affected by the pandemic do you think
certain things will be off limits
or adjusted what's your take
look i think if you're talking about
logistics uh
every business and this is not this one
is not excluded it has been impacted
uh by the pandemic so logistically
getting things in out
how many people you have available to
you that are kind of within the big
brother bubble
are all going to be impacted during uh
this season and so
you know kudos to the entire big brother
team to be able to still be able to pull
this off
given the circumstances i have no
question
uh no concern whatsoever that they're
not going to be
delivering just as good of a season if
not better than they ever have
i think they would have pulled together
an all-star cast
and gotten everybody super excited about
the season if they weren't going to
deliver
so i mean if there's a show that can
happen
where you have to quarantine the
contestants it's big brother
this is it
you